bienvenue dans le débat sur france 24 le
décès d'elizabeth 2 va-t-il raviver les
tensions en irlande du nord entre
unionistes et nationalistes
après les cosses le roi charles iii
était à belfast pour l'hommage à la
reine les responsables politiques ont
tous salué la contribution de la reine
elizabeth ii à la réconciliation
mais la monarchie est contesté par une
grande partie de la population d'irlande
du nord la vice-présidente chef du ching
feng michèle o neal a même boycotté la
proclamation officielle de charles iii
dimanche à hillsborough les
nationalistes du sinn féin ont remporté
une victoire historique en mai dernier
mais la nation nord-irlandaise n'a
toujours pas de gouvernement
l'assemblée locale ne siège plus lé
député unioniste refuse de former un
gouvernement de coalition avec les
républicains du chine fame comme prévu
par les accords de paix du vendredi
saint après les cosses l'irlande du nord
puis les pays de galles où se rend
vendredi le roi que devra-t-il faire le
roi charles iii pour maintenir l'unité
du royaume les strauss nouvelle première
ministre jours at elle un rôle
pacificateur le royaume uni serait-il
désunie au point à d'imploser on en
parle avec mes invités g christophe g le
pardon j'avais plaisir d'avoir à mes
côtés christophe gil ysern bonsoir
gillis nc de le prononcer correctement
professeur de civilisation britannique
et irlandaise à l'université de caen
normandie
bonsoir à vous et bienvenue dans le
débat pascale joannin est également avec
nous bonsoir pascal zingraff général de
la fondation robert schuman la sortie du
rapport schuman c'est pour très bientôt
rapport schuman sur l'europe et sur
l'état de l'union 2022 ça va sortir aux
éditions marie b stephen doc est avec
nous bonsoir si vous êtes photographe
votre dernière exposition à odet willcom
portrait sur l'irlande du nord 40 ans
après le bloody sunday elle s'était
d'abord donc à chalon sur saône et puis
eh bien ça se baladent puisque on la
trouvera donc à la filature de mulhouse
à partir du 15 novembre merci d'être
avec nous par skype de lyon nous avons
avec nos oreilles cambodge bonsoir à
vous professeur de droit à l'université
jean moulin
on 3 vous êtes nord-irlandais vous avez
grandi pendant le conflit en irlande du
nord dans une famille traditionnelle
nationaliste et catholiques j'espère que
c'est bien ça en tout cas vous me
donnerez bien sûr votre point de vue
avant d'ouvrir ses fautes et c'est
correct avant de voir cette discussion
je vous propose de faire un point en
images de cette journée du roi charles
iii qui était donc à belfast
premiers pas en irlande du nord en tant
que monarque pour charles iii et la
reine consort camilia l'étape la plus
délicate de la tournée du nouveau roi
dans les quatre nations du royaume uni
malgré le bain de foule devant des
milliers de personnes au château
d'hillsborough la résidence officielle
de la famille royale la paix conclu en
1998 reste fragile entre unionistes
protestants fidèles à la monarchie
britannique et républicains catholiques
favorable à une réunification avec la
république d'irlande voisine
charles iii souhaite poursuivre le
travail entamé par sa mère la reine
elizabeth deux actrices majeures de la
réconciliation
avec ce brillant exemple devant moi et
avec l'aide de dieu
je prends mes nouvelles fonctions
résolus à rechercher le bien-être de
tous les habitants d'irlande du nord
lors d'une visite en 2012 la reine
elizabeth ii avait serré la main d'un
ancien ministre du parti républicain
chine fine et ancien commandant des
paramilitaires de la ra qui ont
assassiné son cousin en 1979 un geste
perçu à l'époque comme un moment décisif
pour pérenniser le processus de paix la
reine élisabeth ça montrait qu'un petit
geste mais significatif une visite une
poignée de main traverser la rue ou
prononcé quelques mots irlandais peuvent
faire une énorme différence pour changer
les attitudes et construire des
relations
le contexte politique bouleversé par le
brr excite c'est la victoire du ch in
fine aux dernières élections alimente
les incertitudes
le parti républicain nationaliste a
boycotté la proclamation officielle de
charles iii dimanche dernier mais promet
de rencontrer le roi avec d'autres
responsables politiques en conclusion de
sa visite en irlande du nord charles iii
s'est ensuite recueilli à la cathédrale
sainte anne de belfast en mémoire de la
reine elizabeth ii
christophe denis seine pour justement
bien cadrer le débat à l'irlande du nord
a un lien on peut dire tumultueux avec
la monarchie britannique c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire alors ça s'est
beaucoup apaisée depuis quelques temps
notamment 7 à cette occasion lorsqu en
2012 la reine et s'étaient rendus en
irlande du nord est avait serré la main
de martin mcguinness qui avait des dons
qu'un commandant en chef de l'ira et
sans doute impliqués dans le décès de
lord mountbatten en 1979 en oncle oui à
l aliment donc un représentant de la
famille royale de la couronne
britannique de l'impérialisme puisqu'il
avait été le dernier vice roi des indes
c'est pour ça qu'ils avaient été ciblés
donc cette poignée de main avait une
dimension symbolique assez
extraordinaire et avait scellé en
quelque sorte une
peut-être pas une réconciliation parce
que pour le chêne fine l'objectif reste
la réunification ce sont des
républicains mais ils ont adopté une
voie résolument constitutionnel
c'est-à-dire qu'on a vu alex maskey
accueillir le prince charles les députés
élus du chum fine donc ils l'accueillent
selon les règles de l'hospitalité
mais ils ne vont pas assister aux
cérémonies officielles parce que ce
serait reconnaître la légitimité du
pouvoir britannique en irlande du nord
ce à quoi il se refuse il présente des
candidats aux élections nationales
britanniques ils ont des élus mais ces
élus refusent de siéger à west ham
racinaire parce qu' il faudrait prêté
serment la reine et la hausse il s'y
refuse mais tout cela relève d'une
démarche purement constitutionnel
désormais donc c'est tout même complexe
steve jobs steve jobs vous qu'il y avait
photographié justement ces britanniques
est ce que vous êtes allé à belfast
photographie justement dans les rues
c'est l'irlandais du nord s'est
énormément de temps justement au contact
des nord-irlandais des deux communautés
eux
comment ont-ils justement accueillir
cette venue du roi charles iii certains
disent que le roi est responsable du
bloody sunday c'est vrai c'est en fait
ce qu'ils disent ne m'étonne pas après
j'étais pas surpris mais c'est comme
quand quand margaret thatcher est décédé
il ya plein d'anglais qui ont qui ont
célébré la mort de thatcher mais dans le
sens où reese était très très content et
satisfait de sa mémoire était tout de
même en irlande du nord en compte tenu
du contexte que viens d'évoquer
christophe gillison
moi je suis pas parti commandes accord
sur un apaisement l'apaisement politique
n'est pas à l'apaisement sociétal donc
je sais ce que j'ai pu voir en tout cas
dans et croiser dans les rues je vois
que les républicains sont encore
complètement remontée et en plus
maintenant et ont gagné ces élections
ils vont avoir envie d'aller d'aller
plus loin parce qu'ils sentent qu'ils
ont potentiellement 7,7 cette option
après les les
les loyalistes cee je suis plus surpris
parce que quand même ces derniers temps
il y avait des signes un peu de jeu
trouve de faiblesse de la monarchie
quant à leur position avait plus ce côté
on se sent un peu on se sent un peu
abandonné donc je suis surpris et nous
owen gamble vous qui avez grandi au sein
d'une famille nationaliste cette guerre
guerre civile qu'il faut le rappeler
entre 1969 et 1998 a fait plus de 3500
morts c'est toujours un traumatisme en
irlande du nord
bien sûr que si mais il faut dire il
faut dire également que quand on a fait
beaucoup de progrès depuis
la fin de séquence et bien sûr après un
conflit aussi long et aussi dans le ici
que je suis resté un peu mais je crois
que les choses comme avant depuis
toujours comme on dit tout à l'heure les
lieux représentatifs de de chine fait
ils ont parlé avec beaucoup de respect
même avec avec de la chaleur ils ont
fait des déclarations et ils ont salué
ont fait leurs études à contribution
coleraine elle même a fait comme qu'on
avait fait de sa glande visite à touba
il fait référence à cette visite dont on
vient de parler mais là avec ce nouveau
roi est ce que justement c'était pas
problématique
je sais pas trop si c'est problématique
comment le vit de chine fait nous
détacher les irlandais s'est pas
vraiment question qu'ils veulent faire
tomber la monarchie ça c'est pas
vraiment de but ça c'est pas vraiment
dire se faire beau c'est vrai dire que
ils ont ils ont parlé et c'est pas
vraiment touchée par la monuc et ils ont
parlé de mort pour le monde l'équipe
britannique bien sûr ça c'est évident
mais le but c'est la réunification de
l'irlande et si c'est dur si ce jour
arrive et la couronne britannique et
n'est plus grande dans les holland seul
il les rondelles en entière la
continuation ou le futur de la monarchie
ça c'est vraiment question pour les gens
de grande bretagne et j'ai fait la
différence aux cheveux blonds bretagne
et le royaume uni parce que
officiellement le lendemain et est
inclus dans cette dans cette phrase
royaume uni de grande bretagne et de
paris parle de l'ecosse l'angleterre et
le bigard et parce qu'elle jouait dans
ce qu'on peut dire que les tensions se
sont encore accentuées avec après le
bric cité avec cette remise en question
du protocole nord-irlandais avec bruit
johnson notamment ellis trust on sait
pas encore très bien ce qu'il va faire
alors oui il faut voir aussi ça avec un
angle européen d'abord le chine fine
puisque vous en parliez il est à la fois
représente ni relance du nord mais
également l'irlande est signé pour ça
qu'il peut y avoir une unification parce
que le parti a aussi des élus dans la
république d'irlande
au sud le brésil en juin 2016 il ya deux
entités du royaume uni qui ne se sont
pas exprimés pour le brésil c'est
l'ecosse à 62% et l'irlande du nord à
55% donc ces pays à ces pays c'est
nation voulait rester dans le roi dans
l'union européenne et donc
les conservateurs britanniques qui ont
fait ce référendum on pas imaginer un
seul instant que le territoire qu est
une il avait en effet une petite partie
du duo du royaume étaient dans l'île
d'irlande et l'île d'irlande compte tenu
de l'histoire que vient nous convient de
rappeler ne voulait pas restauré une
frontière entre le sud membre de l'union
européenne et le nord qui est membre du
royaume uni et c'était un consensus qui
était partagé par les
le nord et le sud parce qu'il ne voulait
pas retrouvé cette frontière qu'on a eu
tant de mal à enlever etc moyennant quoi
on a inventé un protocole nord-irlandais
entre l'union européenne et l'irlande du
nord qui reste membre du marché
intérieur l'irlande du nord pour crier
pas en effet de frontière à l'intérieur
de sept-îles d'irlande donc c'est une
réplication fiscale ou douanière si je
puis dire et en effet il ya des
contrôles qui sont faits entre le
royaume uni lille et la partie nord
irlandaise de bellefeuille pour
contrôler en effet parce que là c'est et
donc ça c'est ce que les les les breaks
sitter n'accepte pas donc là pour le
coup il y avait un engagement de boris
johnson à remettre tout ça en question
les strauss était sur cette ligne aile à
la peine la pauvre le temps d'être nommé
par la reine que la reine à décéder donc
on va voir mais là pour le coup si
jamais il ya un bras de fer on va avoir
un bras de fer avec bruxelles parce que
c'est la parole de royaume uni qui a été
donné est donc maintenant il reviendrait
dessus il bref il faudrait carrément le
plat lui les et là on sera pas d'accord
je ne sais pas d'ailleurs à lanhélin
plus christophe gillison donc
effectivement ça attise encore les
divisions cette histoire du protocole
non irlandais que pascal janin a bien
être développé ça attise les divisions
est-ce que ça renforce justement la
volonté d'une chine fine de se
rapprocher de faire en sorte qu'une
réunification en irlande est-ce que
charles iii pour être le roi qui va
assister finalement au démembrement du
royaume uni alors on est dans une
situation assez fluide il peut se passer
beaucoup de choses étaient rappelés
effectivement en république d'irlande le
chêne fine et le principal parti
d'opposition et il est très loin devant
les autres partis dans les sondages à
plus de 30% alors ça tient un
positionnement qui est assez habile
c'est à dire qu'ils insiste avant tout
sur les problèmes du logement qui est un
problème majeur en république d'irlande
mais les irlandais qui adhère mais la
réunification fait partie de leur
programme et s'ils sont au pouvoir à
dublin et à belfast effectivement ça
change profondément la donne
ce protocole nord-irlandais a priori a
été conçu comme la moins mauvaise
solution dans le cadre du prêt xi qu'il
fallait éviter à tout prix une frontière
entière l'irlande qui aurait
probablement provoqué une reprise du des
violences donc c'est fragile à ce point
ces accords justement dont on parle du
vendredi saint à qui remonte aux années
90 on fasse rage il à ce point on parle
parfois lorsqu'on évoque l'irlande du
nord d'une paix froide il n'y a plus de
violence mais les deux communautés
protestantes et catholiques reste
distante méfiante n'habitent pas
forcément dans les mêmes quartiers ne
fréquentent pas les mêmes écoles et il y
a toujours ces tensions historiques
culturelles sous jacente qui peuvent
rejaillir et avec le break site on a vu
que ça pouvait effectivement provoqué
les tensions a c'est vrai on a une
dimension politique puisque le delliou
pire refuse de participer à un
gouvernement local comme vous l'avez dit
il n'y a pas de gouvernement en irlande
du nord de fait et donc ca c'est ça
c'est un problème aussi parce qu'on voit
bien que ce dialogue inter-religieux
intercommunautaires et inter politique a
du mal à ce lieu on a en effet d'aider
des jusqu'au boutistes qui dit mais on
veut pas de ce protocole dans les landes
est donc on veut pas siéger dans le
gouvernement donc c'est un petit peu je
te tiens tu me tiens par la barbichette
mais là ça ira ils se rendent compte que
peut-être ils sont en train d'allumer
peut-être un pétard qui risquent de peut
être sauté dans plus ou moins long terme
stéphane lhomme vous aviez eu ce
sentiment en arpentant les rues
justement là bas
le fait que la cicatrice mac ces accords
de paix du vendredi saint finalement
sont fragiles et pourraient être encore
fragilisé à la fois par le break site
mais aussi par un changement de monarque
moi j'ai commencé ce travail
en misant sur le processus de paix c'est
à dire que vraiment il ya le mot avant
paye allemand processus et je pense que
le processus doit être très long et sera
à mon avis très long est-ce qu'il
marchera oui non je ne sais pas en
revanche là où moi je n'ai jamais cru
c'est une flambée petites grandes ou pas
de la violence au moment du bric site
parce que vraiment la population nord
irlandais je pense que des deux côtés
n'ont absolument plus envie de de
connaître des scènes de violence dans la
rue donc oui il ya toujours ces tensions
oui ils ont ils vivent avec des murs qui
séparent les communautés c'est là c'est
là justement où je rejoins monsieur
quand il dit une paix froide je pense
qu'elle est même encore plus que froid
je dirais même glacial parce qu'il ya
quand même des gens qui n'osent pas
franchir ses murs et qui quittent quand
il sort du travail même s'ils
travaillent entre c'est-à-dire
loyalistes et républicains ils n'iront
et qui s'entendent bien au travail ils
n'iront jamais boire un verre en
ensemble à la sortie donc ils vont
rentrer chacun donc ils sont séparés
mais on essaye de ne pas provoquer le
conflit c'est ce que vous dites owen
cahmbers vous êtes d'accord avec ce qui
vient d'être dit est-ce que vous aussi
vous avez la santé le sentiment
finalement qu'à une fragilité de ces
accords de paix mais que malgré tout ils
tiennent même si comme vient de le dire
seven doc finalement eh bien chacun
restent séparées donc ça veut dire quoi
qu'il ya deux sortes des non dits on
n'évoque pas le sujet
mais ça reste chaud est une société
assez divisés et bien sûr dans les longs
de nos efforts comprendre et on faire
résume de la situation dans quelques
minutes donc il ya tellement de nuances
dans notre camp moussa sow imagine
seulement s'il était d'accord
mais il ya des quartiers qui restent
très divisés a bien sûr dont les autres
dans notre
région de l'irlande du nord le community
ce mélange peut que mieux mais ça reste
quelque chose inquiétant les changements
demandent à ce point là est-ce que ça et
ça va créer un prof demos a procuré des
choses honnêtement je crois que ça c'est
pas le plus grand de kg est pour moi
pour moi c'est vraiment des questions
économiques les impacts
le l'avenir avec leur existait il ya un
crise d'énergie qui arrive donc ces
journaux de questions peut créer des
tensions qu'ont les gens que les jeunes
églises en manque de travail et un
montage pendante espoir c c'est assez
facile
de diriger dans dans la mauvaise
direction et on a vu ça avant tout nous
devons malheureusement parce qu'elles
vont être agile donc un d'après ce qu'on
entend doubler ses espèces de statuts
coup bah oui c'est fragile parce que
c'est une
serre défi une solution qui a été trouvé
in extremis
on a essayé de pallier en effet la
préparation des britanniques qui n'avait
pas du tout pour ce fait du gouvernement
britannique qui n'est pas du tout pensé
à ce qu'allait être l'irlande du nord on
leur a proposé la solution mais entendu
on l'a un peu tordu le bras et les
irlandais ont applaudi de chèques de
part et d'autre parce que les irlandais
eux ils veulent en effet la paix le truc
et voulait surtout pas rejouer à
frontière donc en effet il suffit de peu
de choses donc je veux bien qu'on me
dise que ça repartira pas que c est moi
je suis toujours méfiants parce que une
déclaration une situation économique
sociale
on voit les difficultés alors bien
entendu ça va être non pas le rôle du
roi le roi et essayer de fédérer tout ce
qui peut et de prendre le rôle de sa
mère est d'être le garant de l'unité
mais ça va être toute la politique faite
par les spurs donc on va attendre que la
reine soit enterré la semaine prochaine
pour qu'elle reprenne pour voir ce
qu'elle va faire elle avait déclaré
beaucoup de choses dans sa campagne et
elle a annoncé un plan donc entre ce
qu'elle a déclaré pendant la campagne
pour faire avoir les voix des
conservateurs et maintenant qu'elle est
première ministre il va peut-être se
passer des choses pour voir en effet
qu'est ce qu'elle va appliquer et est ce
que la population base va accepter c'est
ces mesures et sa politique est là la
clé est plutôt dans la main du
gouvernement britannique que dans le roi
du dollar dans l'ain dans les mains du
roi christophe gillison d'ailleurs on
l'a vu liste russell a suivi on peut
dire un peu partout charles iii donc
déjà en écosse puisqu'elle était hier à
edimbourg elle était aussi aujourd'hui à
belfast d'ailleurs certains disent
finalement c'est une opportuniste elle
utilise finalement les le décès
d'elizabeth 2 pour justement se mettre
en avant alors c'est la situation n'est
pas forcément simple pour elle est il né
évident pour un observateur extérieur de
savoir exactement ce qu'elle pense et ce
qu'elle cherche à faire effectivement
elle s'était mis dans la foulée de boris
johnson pour se faire élire bon
maintenant qu'elle est première ministre
que va-t-elle faire apparemment du côté
de l'europe de bruxelles de la
commission européenne il ya cette idée
qui a peut-être là un espace politique
qui s'ouvre qui s'entrouvre et donc il y
a eu des propositions des concessions
qui ont été faits sur l'application du
protocole nord-irlandais ça permettra de
tester la volonté la stratégie de listes
ross par rapport à l'irlande du nord
c'est à dire que si elle saisi cette
perche ça pourrait régler un peu le
problème qui avait été maintenue de
manière un peu artificielle par boris
johnson pendant plusieurs mois ses parts
ses homologues européens se peignaient
qu'on ne pouvait pas négocier de bonne
foi avec ris parce qu'il disait quelque
chose et puis il faisait le contraire là
peut-être que avec l'iss trust un
règlement définitif pourrait être
trouvée longuet serait plutôt
pacificatrice peut-être celle paris nice
et le paris de la commission européenne
et c'est effectivement c'est le bon
moment pour voir si on peut remettre les
choses un petit peu decker parce que les
relations entre le bruxelles et londres
depuis plusieurs années était quand même
très compliqué donc il ya peut-être là
un espace qui s'ouvre on verra ce que ce
que ça donnera un stand up vous disais
c'est la politique sociale qui va
compter c'est ce que vous pensez alors
on attend de savoir si effectivement
elle va gueuler par exemple et prix
d'énergie parce qu'elle a dit qu'elle ne
ferait pas mais peut-être que va-t-elle
le faire finalement elle un plan de
plusieurs milliards de livres qui est en
standby puisqu'il faut qu'elles le
fassent avalisé par le parlement qui
pour l'instant en deuil et ce sera la
clé pour pacifier en tout cas l'irlande
je sais que l'actualité veut que l'on se
concentre beaucoup je censure sur le
nouveau roi et sur la politique mais
selon moi on essaie trop d'expliquer en
fait la situation nord-irlandaise part
par la politique alors que même au sein
des communautés pour le coup
républicaine vous allez dans le nord de
belfast à halloween ou une autre une
autre communauté comme ça vous allez
même rencontré des gens qui ne sont
absolument pas d'accord avec avec la
politique d'une chine fine il ya
exactement les mêmes du côté loyaliste
donc moi je pense qu'on est on est plus
sur une division historique parce que
ils sont grands ils ont grandi comme ça
et je trouve que même les nouvelles
générations en fait qu'ils vivent et je
suis d'accord avec avec monsieur que
comment dire que c'est ancré que ça va
mieux donc si vous allez à belfast dans
le quartier économique oui les divisions
vous les allées pas les sentir si vous
allez dans un belfast de la fête à
l'université vous n'allez pas les sentir
dès que vous quittez le centre ville
vous allez en périphérie que ce soit sur
la gauche ou sur la droite vous allez
retomber dans les quartiers comme ça et
ça vous le trouvez à derry après il ya
d'autres villes qui sont même sur la
côte comme carrickfergus qui sont comme
des bastions donc moi je vous là on sent
qu'une étincelle pourrait
je pense vraiment pas une étincelle jeu
j'y crois je devrais je leur souhaite
absolument pas et c'est surtout je n'y
crois pas parce que il personne n'a
envie de retourner dans les troubles et
personne n'a envie de de revoir comme
dit ces violences dans la rue tu pas
dire qu'ils sont d'accord les uns avec
les autres mais il ya cette situation un
peu de de guerre froide de paix froide
je sais pas trop comment dans quel sens
le dire mais qui est là et qui selon moi
ne bouge pas pour l'instant powell les
avancé owen campbell est ce que vous
pensez que les strauss justement un rôle
important à jouer à la fois donc à
l'égard du protocole nord irlandais mais
également sociales pour justement éviter
que les tensions soient de plus en plus
importante en irlande du nord oui oui
bien sûr c est donc le lot de laits ce
jeu c'est beaucoup beaucoup plus
important que celui de war qu est ce qu
est largement symbolique
je crois que il ya plusieurs challenges
et strauss en ce moment il ya ces
questions de l'économie du président
frontière environ du nord également les
crosses et cross c'est une grande
question à ce que le mouvement pour
l'indépendance
ça reste quelque chose
qui n'est pas disparus dont les corps
c'est peut-être qui devient encore plus
fort et quelque chose qui est peut-être
mal compris hors de l'irlande l'on sait
que la situation des causses island en
france selon alain durand parce que la
communauté
protestante organiste il faut noter que
la région est aujourd'hui 1 200 300 dont
l'histoire 500 dans l'histoire mais leur
horizon pour le globe des sons et kroos
et c'est peut-être mal compris majorité
des protestants en irlande du nord ne
sont pas des preuves presbytérien et ça
c'est l'église de l'ecosse et la france
de l'ecosse et avait donc dans le dans
l'écriture de cette humilité h les
projectiles d'y aller les cornemuses et
parmi eux un dialecte qui sait le all
star kartz donc pour moi si
l'indépendance de l'écran cerise ça peut
être un moment difficile peut-être pour
pour la communauté a une histoire il en
europe et est une crise des 30 et ça
c'est quelque chose
parce que j'en ai à ce qui pourrait même
y avoir une sorte d'effet domino c'est à
dire que ça pourrait démarrer en écosse
et puis continuer ben saad adrien
calendrier en écosse en écosse on a vu
tout puisque la reine est décédé en
écosse pour ça qu'on a eu deux premières
la première cérémonie dans cette église
d'ailleurs vous aviez dit monsieur qui
n'est pas en l'état voilà mes bonbons
l'icann voilà donc on a eu en effet hier
la cérémonie à edimbourg est donc élevé
la première ministre écossaise qui a
fait qu elle et qu'elle lui nicolas
store jeunes-là sturgess et nicole est
en jaune depuis le mois de juin de cette
année donc avec elizabeth ii et boris
johnson compte tenu du fait que le parti
national écossais gagne les élections
depuis plusieurs années 2007 que ils
sont majoritaires dans la dans la
représentation des sièges et cosea à
westminster a dit mais moi je vais faire
un référendum en octobre 2023 ce sera le
deuxième a eu lieu en 2014 qui a été
refusé par les écossais à l'époque 55%
mais elle dit moi là je l'utiliserai
existant qui est l'argument de faits
nouveaux de 2016 en disant moi je
voulais pas sortir du soin je sois vous
me faites à quelque chose soit jeu on va
quitter le royaume uni peut-être pas la
couronne britannique on va quitter le
le royaume-uni donc yaya ce processus
pour ça il faut qu'ils aient l'accord du
premier ministre de la première ministre
elle a saisi la cour suprême donc être
déjà un procès déjà dans celui ci le
processus va à son terme on va voir mais
elle a décidé de faire un alors au mieux
à nara référendum en octobre 2003 sinon
utilisez les élections générales de 2024
au royaume-uni puisque selon le mandat
de lee strauss et deux ans puisqu'elle
prend la succession de bons rails
johnson et d'utiliser ces élections pour
donc on est en cause toutes les façons
c'est cette firme indépendantiste existe
c'est un terreau fort et en effet je
suis d'accord avec vous monsieur quand
même si ça se décante de cette manière
là en écosse ça je peux pas vous dire si
ce sera cette manière là où une autre il
va y avoir une retour une scène
soubresauts en irlande du nord puisque
là pour le coup le royaume à être un
petit peu tanguay même si on reste
attaché à la couronne par ailleurs
christologie ça nous est donc en fait il
pourrait assister à un début d'implosion
du royaume du royaume uni ce nouveau roi
charles ii iii est ce que vous le pensez
qu'il ya un lien entre ce qui se passe
en écosse et où on m'a expliqué sur ce
plateau hier que le lien entre l'écossé
l'angleterre est même très différent
puisque les costes n'a jamais été
colonisé par les anglais donc ils ont un
rapport à la monarchie peut-être
différent à des irlandais qui pourrait
sortir tout en restant la couronne en
revanche en irlande c'est encore plus
complexe mais ce qu'il pourrait
effectivement si les écossais décidé de
sortir justement du royaume uni est ce
que ça pourrait entraîner avoir des
conséquences importantes en irlande je
suis persuadé que si le royaume uni
commencé à se déliter ça commencerait
peut-être par l'ecosse et après il y
aurait un effet dans l'aube on sait
aussi que ça a commencé plus tôt avec
les causes plutôt qu en irlande du nord
il me semble oui en irlande du nord
l'objectif pour l'instant c'est de
régler ces questions de d'assemblée qui
ne fonctionne pas qui est suspendue
depuis le 1er février et de trouver une
solution définitive pour les échanges
les contrôles douaniers la réunification
et bien sûr dans les esprits notamment
eu lieu dans le chai les représentants
du chêne faille mais c'est peut-être à
plus long terme la en écosse la pression
est forte 2023 2024
parce qu'il faut bien comprendre que en
2014 lors du référendum il n'y a eu que
55% des électeurs qui se sont exprimés
qui ont voté pour le maintien dans le
royaume uni c'est peu ça montre la
fragilité du lien est l'un des arguments
clés en 2014 c'était si vous sortez du
royaume uni vous sortez de l'union
européenne par la même occasion or les
écossais sont très pro-européens très
contrairement aux anglais donc là s'ils
veulent rester dans l'union européenne
salue marty des arguments donc
aujourd'hui s'il y avait un nouveau
référendum en 2023/2024 par exemple la
question serait est-ce que vous
souhaitez quitter le royaume uni pour
entrer à nouveau dans l'union européenne
hélas le résultat pourrait être très
différents donc je pense que à londres
listrat se fera tout ce qu'elle peut
pour empêcher ce référendum mais il y a
une certaine dynamique qui qui est
présente ça c'est certain vous êtes
d'accord et stéphane bak on connaissait
aussi les costes j'imagine oui oui et
non mais je oui oui oui mais je pense
qu'un jour je me suis dit que j'allais à
les franchir le bras le bras mer mais
oui si les causes en effet un bas vers
indépendant je pense que ça soufflera un
vent qui clairement
influencé le nord de l'irlande après moi
il ya toujours aussi une question qui
reste est ce que l'irlande va vouloir
intégrer le nord de l'irlande savent
quand vous discutez avec certains
irlandais ils sont pas tous d'accord
donc je pense que c'est quand même
encore assez compliqué pour dire oui non
est ce qu'il y aura ou est ce qu'il y
aura pas pour l'irlande pour l'irlande
vit owen campbell effectivement est ce
que les la république d'irlande
accepterait
l'irlande du nord
je crois que je comprends cette question
parce que c'est vrai que il y a des
inquiétudes
pour absorber lit alors de nom mais il
faut il faut comprendre que ce serait
presque impossible pour un parti dans de
l'eau polluée l'ordre de faire la
campagne contre le benfica sursis et un
rien si on le fera
demain est ce qu'une partie pour faire
la campagne contre pour voter de nos
c'est un peu ça reste un peu comme le
sacré dans mes lentilles d'eau dans les
rangs de cette édition pour ce dans le
sud il faut rester au moins même si
c'est pas très facile mais il faut
rester un peu trop dans l'unification
des mois c'est qu'il n'y a pas de
référendums organisés par exemple en
irlande du nord comme c'est le cas en
écosse il non on n'a pas l'impression
qu'il ait brandi cette arme
bien joué et il faut comprendre qu'on
sort de
13 ans de conflit à l'est lors d'une
origine des d'un conflit et puis on
avait une génération où il y avait
beaucoup de discrimination beaucoup des
inégalités et puis le conflit aurait
commencé et ça continue jusqu'au
jusqu'au les années 90 donc c'est pas
vraiment une situation chronique os où
ils ont eu un référendum dans les pays
où c'était vraiment juste une question
impression de politique tout le monde
les droits de son vote soit avec
l'accord de vendredi saint et à des
conditions très bien défini pour l'heure
le monde donc ce n'est pas quelque chose
qu'on peut juste un nom si demain ça
qu'il faut avoir d'accord il faut avoir
en votre minimum mais comme on avoue
avec les adoptions les élections pour
les deux sens mais original tout
récemment je crois qu'on arrive presque
à ce moment précis pas quelque chose qui
peut être forcé tout de suite et ça
c'est le plus dangereux pour le forcer
tout de suite donc il faut attendre le
bon moment mon avis est ce que puisqu'il
nous reste quatre minutes je fais un
tour de table parce qu'elle est ce que
vous pensez qu effectivement le roi
charles iii va assister à un royaume
désunis alors je sais pas ce qu'il va se
passer et oui mais s'ouvre une ère
nouvelle de toutes les façons parce que
la reine a quarter plutôt le xxème
siècle avait connu la guerre donc c'est
la fin c'est la fin d'une époque donc 70
ans et mieux que la reine victoria donc
donc ce ne sera pas forcément un mois de
transition parce que s'il a les gènes de
son père et de sa mère et va vivre assez
longtemps donc au moins une vingtaine
d'années donc mais par contre c'est très
nouveau donc est-ce que l'adhésion qui
était à la reine qui était là la grand
mère va être le même pour pour charles
ça c'est une autre affaire il ya en
effet ces tentatives de deux
d'indépendantisme en
négoce et de réunification qui prend de
plus en plus de place et pas le fait
majeur mais on en parle on en parle de
plus en plus donc c'est des points sur
lequel lui va devoir payer puisqu'il est
le garant un petit peu de cette unité
donc il a des mots a dit il peut pas
faire de politique et on va voir en
effet par les actes qu'il fera s'il
arrive à un peu remettre les choses à
plat
en effet en effet il a quand même
quelque chose qui va être nouveau donc
on sait pas du tout dans quel sens ça va
se dérouler avec en effet des élections
dans deux ans pour pour peut-être que
nouvelle majorité ou quelque chose qui
donnera christophe gsm comment voyez
vous les choses c'est au royaume pour
être désunie il
vivait ce profonde et qui semble très
difficile de contenir et le monarque eu
plus jouer un rôle symbolique il ne
faudrait pas surestimer ce rôle là s'il
a choisi en accord avec gouvernement
certainement de fer s'est tournée de
toutes les régions constitutive de du
royaume uni c'est un signal qui montre
la cava j'ai été élevé dans l'absolu
mans donc c'est ça montre que le pouvoir
et la couronne ont bien conscience de la
fragilité actuelle du royaume uni ce que
le monarque pourra y changer grand chose
je nuis ce je n'en suis pas persuadé il
me semble que là ce qui peut changer les
choses c'est le gouvernement au pouvoir
à londres depuis
2010 c'est un gouvernement conservateur
le parti conservateur depuis plusieurs
décennies est devenu un parti de plus en
plus anglais ils n'ont quasiment aucun
élu en écosse quasiment aucun élu en
irlande du nord donc finalement ils ne
représentent que l'angleterre
essentiellement et avec ce brésil ils
ont mis en avant un projet nationaliste
anglais auquel les écossais et beaucoup
de personnes en irlande du nord ne
peuvent pas adhérer parce que c'est un
projet anglais qui n'est pas le leur qui
leur a été imposé puisque ça a été dit
pendant le référendum de 2016 les
écossais les irlandais on vote non
irlandais ont voté contre le break sic
non leur imposent les anglais leur
impose et là il me semble que dès lors
les conditions commencent à être un peu
réuni pour que ce royaume implose
puisque vous dit s'il y avait un
changement de gouvernement en 2024 par
exemple un retour des travaillistes
peut-être peut-être cette dynamique
pourrait elle être au moins ralenti
merci beaucoup peut-être un dernier mot
vous allez nous reste une minute au rink
à mort
qu'il peut jouer le roi charles je sais
pas s'il peut il peut faire grand chose
à mon avis
c'est vrai que c'est peut-être la fin
d'une époque c'est vrai que en irlande
et non 5 à petit qu'il ya ceux qui sont
qu'ils ont pour le moment chez ceux qui
sont contre mais également il ya
beaucoup d'idées le public 1 et j'ai
donc dans le grande bretagne et j'ai pas
par le républicain dans le sens de
violon de cette situation mais je parle
de ceux qui sont peut-être contre la
monarchie et mais même ces gens et il
avait un respect pour leur haine et de
7,2 peut-être respect forcé mais
c'était un respect individuel pour
propos la femme en question parce que
même si on la prend tout le monde à qui
il faut reconnaître qu'elle a fait
qu'elle a fait ses obligations donc avec
beaucoup d'honneur avec beaucoup de
respectabilité donc je me demande si
c'est charles peut hériter cette hausse
fait et je m'en doute en fait royaume
au royaume des unis en tout cas la
question reste entière merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous christophe
gillison merci pascal jouanna merci à
vous et stephen la doc merci aux webcams
bol d'avoir été avec nous par skype de
lyon merci à vous tous de leur suivi et
rester avec nous sur 64